der Frühling kommt und sie wissen ja was
das heißt abspecken ist angesagt selbst
unser Bundestag arbeitet gerade am neuen
Beach body die Ampel hat eine
Wahlrechtsreform durchgedrückt der
Bundestag wird endlich kleiner ja
Natur ab der nächsten dürfen noch
maximal
630 Abgeordnete rein Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate werden abgeschafft im
Moment haben wir mit 736 noch das größte
frei gewählte Parlament der Welt das ist
zu viel das ist viel zu viel
Gastroenterologen sprechen schon vom äh
Bundestag Bundestag nee Bundestag
aufgeblähte Bundestagswahl Bundestag wie
bei einem dicken Kind gilt auch hier
wenn man nichts unternimmt bläht sich
alles immer weiter auf
erzähl mehr von zu Hause mein Gott
da empfehlen wir kimchimea Reichstag pro
mit der natürlichen Kraft der 5% Hürde
so was steht drin im neuen
ampelwahlrecht die Streichung der
sogenannten grundmandatsklausel sie
besagt wer unter 5% bleibt aber
mindestens drei Direktmandate holt kommt
trotzdem mit Fraktion in den Bundestag
sowie zuletzt die Linken das wäre dann
jetzt bald vorbei während
4,9% reichen beim nächsten Mal nur noch
für einen Platz auf der Parkbank
entsprechend persönlich nehmen Sie die
Sache
feststellen dass sie mit Änderungsantrag
also hier hin gerotzt mal eben kurz zwei
Oppositionsparteien aus dem Bundestag
politisch eliminieren wollen
[Applaus]
ja danach hat er eine E-Gitarre
zertrümmert
und einer Fledermaus den Kopf abgebissen
tatsächlich hätte man es auch bei der
Obergrenze 630 Abgeordnete belassen
können ohne Last Minute die
grundmandatsklausel zu killen vielleicht
ein bisschen viel Brechstange jetzt
fühlt sich die ohnehin angeschlagene
linke natürlich total gelingt ist ja
klar
kann man auch nachvollziehen im Prinzip
ist das kappungsmodell schon ganz
vernünftig weil im Gegensatz zu einer
Zusammenlegung von Wahlkreisen schnell
umsetzbar trotzdem wird vorm Reichstag
garantiert zu unschön sind kommen im
Grunde wie vom Berghain grüß Dich nee
nee heute geschlossene Gesellschaft nur
für Stammgäste mit mehr als 5 %. ich
komme mir das ganze Jahr rein ich kenne
Olaf voll ja den kenn ich auch machen
uplook hallo Frau Weidel gut schauen Sie
aus
finde ich nicht so ein Eigentor hat sich
die Ampel allerdings garantiert
geschossen wenn die Union in der
nächsten Regierung sitzt dann kommt
direkt die nächste Reform hat Friedrich
Merz schon angedroht unser Wahlrecht ist
nämlich gar nicht im Grundgesetz
verankert und das bedeutet wenn ich mich
nicht bitte Opposition auf irgendwas
einige kriege ich alle vier Jahre was
neues Ideen lassen wir die Bürger doch
direkt ihr Wahlrecht mitwählen in der
Kabine ja klar da kann man dann ganz
unten auf dem Stimmzettel ankreuzen was
man nur am besten findet nee
Mehrheitswahlrecht
Verhältniswahlrecht oder Nordkorea ich
habe die AGBs gelesen und möchte den
Newsletter der Bundesregierung
abonnieren und rein optional wer aus der
aktuellen Staffel soll Germany's next
Topmodel werden
ich bin ja Team Coco aber das nur am
Rande zurück zum neuen Wahlrecht meine
Damen und Herren über das regt sich
neben der Linkspartei vor allem die CSU
auf Alexander Dobrindt ist in der
Debatte im Bundestag so abgegangen die
saldine hatten schon das
Betäubungsgewehr ausgepackt ja ja gut
klar ist die CSU angepisst ne die holen
in Bayern traditionell fast alle direkt
Mandate mit denen man aber demnächst
nicht mehr automatisch dabei ist auf der
anderen Seite hat die Söder Gang fast
alle Reformvorschläge der letzten Jahre
eisern abgeblockt ne jetzt ist natürlich
ordentlich Dampf in der Debatte ich
wünsche Ihnen politisch alles erdenklich
schlechte wir werden uns in Karlsruhe
sehen
[Applaus]
es ist ein schämlichkeit nicht für
überwiegen Arsch hoch dann kommt ja auch
über die 5%
[Applaus]
lassen meine Damen und Herren
uh kotz Blitz ein Schurkenstück das
Jugendwort des Jahres 1812
wenn statt rumzuheulen könnte die CSU
doch einfach in ganz Deutschland
antreten aber nein sie spielen lieber
weiter die beleidigte söderwurst ja ist
ja so ja sie wollen die Vorteile einer
Regionalpartei und trotzdem den
garantieren Stammplatz im Bundestag
Dietmar Wischmeyer meint selbst wenn das
jetzt ein Abschied wird für linke und
CSU daraus kann so viel Neues entstehen
[Musik]
ja es war kein feiner Zug von der Ampel
im Handstreich den kleinen Parteien die
Direktmandate als sicherer
Eintrittskarte zu entziehen also außer
der FDP die hat gar keine als einzige
Partei im Bundestag ich sage Kopf hoch
linke wenn ihr euch zusammen tut reicht
das locker für 5 %. nennt euch einfach
weiß ich nicht ja bayerisch
kommunistische Alternative oder CSU die
christliche sozialistische
Untergrundbewegung mit dem neuen Spitzen
du Söder und Zenzi Wagenknecht und dann
fordert ihr Sachen wie eine Pkw-Maut
aber nur für reiche Ausländer oder so da
gemeinsam angreifen statt jammern das
geht der Ampel nicht um eine
Verkleinerung des Bundestages sondern
Schwächung der Opposition und dann nicht
Schwächung Bayerns die ampelschwäche
Bayern klar
was das Ansehen des Freistaats schwächt
ist buchstäblich alles was Markus Söder
postet sich selbst als Oberförster
verkleidet zum Beispiel oder sein zu
tiefst verstörender advents-pullover der
zu mehr Kirchenaustritten geführt als
Kardinal Wölki
die Linke behauptet das Wahlrecht sei
nur dazu da ihr den Todesstoß zu
versetzen lächerlich als bräuchte die
Linke Hilfe von außen der legte sich
doch gerade selbst die sadistische
Wagenknecht plant weiter ihre eigene
Bewegung und dominiert trotzdem den
alten laden wenn ich darf Sie ganz
herzlich begrüßen das ist die also
Konferenz der Fraktion also ich begrüße
Sie auch ganz herzlich
Presse Bernd das ist meine Show
Königin Sarah mit erschütternden
Fehlstunden im Bundestag und
gleichzeitig Nebeneinkünften von der
dreiviertel Millionen in den letzten
zwei Jahren
sie setzt halt andere Prioritäten vor
allem Talkshow Auftritte und den Rest
der Zeit kümmerte sich um die
abgehängten der Gesellschaft vor allem
um ältere die von der SPD vergessen
wurden aber ist das neue Wahlrecht
wirklich eine gute Idee hätte schon beim
letzten Mal gegolten die CSU
Landesgruppe wäre nur 11 Mandate kleiner
dafür dass Theater kennt man wenigstens
einen von den elf die dann raus werden
ich nehme alles zurück ihre Form ist
super gute Nacht allerseits
[Applaus]
kaum wir müssen Strom sparen mach die
Kamera aus Jürgen heute machen wir Asma
Pferde